collias est ce que vous nous avez été
tenté de convertir les ça non je n'ai
jamais été tenté d'être encore pire à
l'islam mais jeunes étaient pressés par
un ami musulman il ya quelques années le
mali une zone homme de foi vous devriez
nous rejoindre je lui ai dit écoutez
pour moi il ya une montagne unique que
nous gravissons les uns et les autres
par des sentiers différents avec
l'espoir de nous retrouver au dessus des
nuages
un jour dans la lumière au sommet bon il
m'a dit oui je comprends bien votre
votre image riche très beau cette
convergence des deux nouveaux chantiers
différents mais au fond il est resté
convaincu que son sentier lui était non
seulement le meilleur probablement mais
même peut-être le seul possible et il ya
un argument pour les musulmans qui est
fort que l'on ne pense pas toujours
suffisamment c'est la région
chronologique pour eux leur prophète
avis méprise pas les autres voulaient
prédécesseur bienvenue mais leurs
professeurs étant le dernier est venu
sceller la prophétie fonds dans
l'économie actuelle tu rates et monsieur
j'ai raté ma n'abîme mais le au chaud
les brevets mais leur livre di pasta bar
où il elle rate
efforcez-vous vers les biens suprême
c'est dieu qui arbitrera entre vous il
dit ça aux chrétiens et aux juifs et aux
musulmans
c'est dans le corps j'ai le droit je
vous laisse finir alors vous le
lhermitte de vézelay